hallo mein name ist luca und ich liebe
früchte über alles doch dann gibt es
noch reihen und der liebe reihen hat
noch nie in seinem leben eine frucht
gegessen mein name ist bis zum heutigen
tage verein absolut also seine eltern
haben ihm versucht früchte zu geben so
dass er sie ist und sich gesund ernährt
aber er hat immer nein gesagt aber wie
gesagt auch da gebe ich sie auf jeden
fall recht reihen wenn man sich gesund
ernährt um beispielsweise eine menge
früchte ist dann sieht man besser aus
mann ist gesünder man lebt gesünder und
ich finde es auch sehr schön dass du
nach keine ahnung ich glaube du bist 30
oder so dass jetzt auch 30 jahren auf
die idee kommen eine frucht zu essen
dk
das ist einfach
das
so okay du hast eine fruchtige weißweine
ananas aussieht wie kannst du etwas
nicht mögen was du angeblich noch nicht
gegessen hast
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn aber gut
meine damen und herren liebe reihen
probiert jetzt als allererstes eine
blaubeere fürchtet apple ja kommen jetzt
packst du dir einfach im mund
[Musik]
drei wochen später das im bau
er lässt sich eine halbe minute zeit und
schauspieler des todes auf wie sonstwas
um dann zu sagen da müssen beim menschen
nicht gesund ziemlich abstoßend aber gut
mein lieber reihen was würdest du denn
der blaubeere zeichen dass skala von 0
bis 10
für eine zahl geben 3m praise of time
also seine bewertung hin oder her aber
dieser satz ein produkt reinbeker andere
leute sind stolz auf sich wenn sie eine
klasse klausur schreiben wenn sie einen
fallschirmsprung schaffen du bist stolz
auf dich weil du eine blaubeere gegessen
als herzlichen glückwunsch rein als
nächstes probiert unser lieber freund
hier allerdings eine weintraube und als
allererstes fragte nach einem messer
welcher mensch schneidet eine weintraube
durch bevor sie ist ja rein aber der hat
auch noch nicht gegessen
[Musik]
genau könne als nächstes probiert rainer
eine erdbeere und da muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen ich liebe ihn über alles
ich finde erdbeeren sind das ganze zu
essen was eigentlich gibt neben pizza
aber pizza ist keine frucht bist du
wahnsinnig wenn sind dass geister auf
der welt also in fachkreisen nennt man
das tvh ii wj freunde hat zwar noch nie
eine frucht gegessen aber ich war noch
nie auf dem mond und weiß wie der mond
aussieht dann weißt du ja fast eine kiwi
ist dieser typ
es ist wirklich unfassbar kann youtube
das nicht bitte sperren
[Musik]
was rein findet es gut dass eine mango
keine eben sicher welche frucht hat
einer in sich haben sagt du hast deinen
freunden gesagt du wirst dich heute mit
einer mango auf einer anderen ebene
verbinden
das ist eine scheiß frucht ne das ist
nicht jesus oder so doch nun probiert
reihen einen apfel und trifft danach
eine tatsächlich wertvolle aussage für
die wissenschaft hat es bergab und dies
war laut rhein schmeckt ein apfel wie
apfelsaft also darauf wäre ich ja
überhaupt nicht gekommen
[Musik]
hier wohl eine baby probiert die freunde
spaß beiseite das war gerade eine banane
aber da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
bananen also wenn ich noch nie eine
banane gegessen hätte würde ich mir auch
erst mal denken was ist das für eine
schleimige scheiße naja jetzt probiert
da die ananas geht langsam wirklich
sympathisch also eine banane mag ich
selber auch nicht so gerne und anderen
das finde ich auch voll geil also mal
schauen was er als nächstes hier sagt zu
wassermelone
ich liebe wassermelone ich dachte du
bist der einzige der keine fast melone
markt die wassermelone stimmt mal ab
hier und wenn irgendein darauf mein
trägt alter dann komme ich nach hause
und schenke euch 40 wasser minute
[Applaus]
eines scheint also darauf kann man
wirklich stolz sein
das canopen haben hier passen würde das
ist
das ist tatsächlich auf was was
armstrong nach der mondlandung sagen
könnte hamburgs koppenpass wurde an der
stelle wenn ich mir heute geht wie die
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren wenn euch meine
reaction auf diesen typen namens reihen
gefallen hat dallas gerne ein like da
unter diesem video hier falls sie noch
kein abonnent zeit dann klickt auf
abonnieren unter dem video aber dann
seid ihr offizieller teil der lu crew
und wir sehen uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
ein